this is the Microsoft Surface RT it's
microsoft's new tablet made by microsoft
itself first time they've made their own
computer it's an ARM based tablet that
means it's running the same kind of
processor that you probably have in your
phone right now and it's running an
operating system called Windows RT
that's basically kind of a stripped-down
version of Windows 8 as you can see it
has a keyboard which is pretty neat for
a tablet the has two different kinds you
can buy one is the type cover which I've
got hooked on right here and the other
is the touch cover which is next to me
to swap them out easy as that couldn't
be easier and it also you'll notice it's
standing upright on its own that's
because it's got this groovy little
built-in kickstand whole thing still
folds down like you'd expect a tablet to
though how does the keyboard work it's
pretty great when I'm typing on the
touch cover which is this little three
millimeter thick keyboard it you know
i'm not getting full speed but i'm doing
pretty well still making some typos but
when i hook up the type cover it's nice
actual physical keys it's thicker but
not noticeably so it still folds down
nicely fits in your bag nicely but you
can really blazed away at this i can
type it basically the same speed on this
that i do on my regular laptop so this
is running basically a version of
windows 8 its new hardware and new
software and what you're going to find
is that it does some things really well
and some things not as well I really
love it I love it for mobile computing
or I don't love it so much is that the
apps are pretty limited you're not going
to have like a lot of stuff in there
that you probably use everyday and you
can only get them through the windows
store it's the same thing Apple does
with their itunes store but there's a
lot more in apple store than there is on
this one but there's also a lot to love
it's a beautifully designed product it
feels great it works well I love
watching movies on it because it's got
the 16 9 aspect ratio which means it's
basically like a real Hollywood
movie without those black bars taking up
your screen real estate like you get on
a most other tablet screens you can't
run traditional Windows programs on this
it's got a desktop but it's almost just
there to confuse you because the only
programs that you're going to find on
there are a handful of microsoft office
programs that are optimized for Windows
RT if you've got all kinds of legacy
programs that you think you're going to
be running on this you are going to be
disappointed one of the things that's
pretty neat is like if you're
multitasking you can really go back and
forth between apps very quickly so like
let's say like you know okay well now
i'm in my desktop but i wanna listen a
little Wayne I want to do some email hey
it's little Wayne okay I'm gonna play my
I'm gonna play a little Wayne now yeah
alright but actually I kind of want to
maybe get something done to somebody go
back to my email and run little Wayne in
the sidebar here that's pretty neat this
is a great device if you think you're
getting windows 8 you're not and you
should know that they'll be disappointed
but if you think you're getting a great
tablet that works well as a laptop and
that's something totally new you're
probably gonna love this
you